[Music]
take your friends
[Music]
are you around here so I'll go easy on
you
Nancy Pelosi
oh
[Music]
look at that picture
[Music]
thank you for taking my questions
[Music]
okay yeah so we both want a ticket to
China multiple people right here have
been raped and this is not 1900 people I
don't know what you have computer War
tennis shoe syndrome I have no idea keep
the content clean gentlemen
Silicon Valley Strike
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
oh glad to be with you and of course you
should be terrified today because the
right-wing guineas are coming the right
wing guineas are coming
it doesn't roll off the top I've been
watching CNN this morning in case you
guys haven't noticed today obviously
Italy uh just had a shift uh in their
government if you look at the voting and
it's reflective of a large swing that we
see across Europe I wonder why that
could be
um we'll get into that are they far
right wing are they the uh The Offspring
the mutated offspring of Mussolini who
by the way was a socialist up until the
day he died no not exactly we'll talk
about that we'll get into the segment we
talked about last week Gerald and I
mentioned this uh the excess deaths in
Europe
we didn't do it last week because we
have to be really careful because you
cannot
suggest right why young able-bodied
people are dying uh in record numbers
we have a hunch now we'll also be
talking with Alex Jones drop if I've
been uh watching that in a recap and uh
how the left is kind of attacked him and
it's not the way that you would think
they are going to be attacking Alex
Jones it's always an attack on
authenticity and legitimacy
don't buy into it uh so my question to
you before we move on here today is why
do you think that so many European
countries have decided to swing
quote-unquote radical right wing extreme
right wing and by that we mean you know
they would be like George Will
Republicans
when you're talking about the political
Spectrum uh Dave is not in today just so
you know he is his the procedure went
well with a family member but there's
some follow-up that needs to be done so
he should be in I believe Wednesday and
we're going to have an extra episode uh
Friday of Life advice for you here on
the mug club uh but as always we have
Gerald a how are you I'm doing well hey
look thousandth episode I think we
should maybe celebrate it
baby all right I don't like it I think I
think we should do more of it like you
know maybe share our favorite story I
don't like you know maybe from all of
them
Joe Lewis is going nuts Joe Lewis that's
uh you know what hold on saying I'm
gonna not happy all right well I'm doing
this
all right when I first met Stephen
guys I'm gay no that was not the
insinuation there no but I mean it'd be
great if maybe we went around the room
and everybody shared their favorite
story about you know maybe oh it's so
self-congratulatory when people do this
and their thousandth episode but you
didn't even know
when I came in I was like do what
made the balloons yeah
my favorite memory is when I used to
have a mute button for Gerald I don't
know why I got rid of that we definitely
I got rid of that what are you talking
about so a thousand episodes I've been
going back to 2009 uh you know back when
I was the the OG grifter I'm surprised
they haven't shot you yet so in uh
Dave's Place we have craw daddy is how
Dave uh call them uh pop scrotter how
are you sir good I remember that poorly
framed bed sheet yes
poorly I know it drives Tim crazy look
up the upper left corner and he didn't
even frame that right no I did not that
was back before we even at digital I
used a I used a super eight now uh David
I'm running back in front of the camera
after hitting the button David are going
to be on tour of course you can go to a
lot of crowders.com tour November 12th
we added a show in Nashville November
12th at 9 30 show and then Baltimore
December 3rd those are the only two
shows with tickets left okay thank you
thousandth episode you can you know what
hit a like button share if you can it
helps with the algorithm comment below
what your favorite memory or your
favorite aspect of the show is and I'm
sure some of you will argue with other
people about which aspect you like and
which how they're wrong because that's
how it works on the internet you didn't
even ask me what mine was
[Laughter]
Ben Shapiro was there he turned into a
meme for two weeks because his reaction
he didn't realize Ben Shapiro did not
know that I was actually going to be
water no a close second was when the
coffee beans were put into the the
concave chest you used to have that had
to have surgery to fix we had no idea
that it was a genetic anomaly that was
causing serious irreparable damage to my
heart yeah that's why and Tim Kennedy
said it was the longest waterboarding
outside of the military he'd ever
witnessed even on Rogan and said you you
tapped out or something in like four
seconds yeah that's the weird thing it's
like why would you say something that's
verifiably false all the time
so
move on uh to this here um oh okay I
guess there was an interaction with and
this is going to bring us into a
conversation about uh trigger warning
rape because I have opinions to be clear
I'm anti right it anti yes it's being
rape correct I'm against the raping we
think it's but here's an entitled woman
but I but I also don't always buy it
like believe all women I believe some
women
and there are some that I don't
call me old-fashioned here's a woman in
uh Walmart who cut in line and then of
course goes to uh The Psychotic rape
card
s
I didn't touch your neighbor
no one did that is this a prank
did the rapist run through a weird out
look-alike convention
that's because she was raped you jerk
well she wasn't sorry when she cut in
line
I just asked her if she saw anyone in
line
don't just leave
[Laughter]
you know there's some kid there heard
the scream and he thought he passed by
like one of those Halloween sensors at
the display he's like why he's not doing
it anymore like a skeleton
gosh you're making it work s i picture a
man and I remove all the reason and
accountability
that's what an adult does you make your
problems everybody else's problems
including strangers
surprised she was wearing a mask no I'm
not not at all tip off blue hair mask
backpack I'm totally sane look kids
backpack look it's backpack can we all
agree that rape is bad yes I missed last
month's meeting are we still we're still
again that's right it's your duty to pay
your dues
um also we don't even like losing butts
we just hit the Subscribe it's just
these unrealistic beauty standards we
change them every week so look we're all
against the rape okay just to be clear
so what I'm about to say is not an
apologist for the the rapist like that
man at Walmart clearly guilty of rape of
course as she insinuated yeah but
understanding that rape is primarily a a
crime of I know you're gonna say it's a
crime of power okay get it whatever uh
it's primarily a crime of wanting to
have sex with someone who doesn't want
to have sex with you and so you have sex
with them anyway
wouldn't it stand to reason that the
victims of rape
would usually not always generally be
those who are most desirable sexually
considering the crime maybe like the
fives to tens I mean like you don't
carjack a 98 Oldsmobile no and this and
it's always ladies like that who are
claiming they're raped I've searched and
I could be wrong about this there are
many right how many times I've been to a
change in my mind it's always a blue
haired would-be lesbian feminists who
claim they're raped as far as I know not
one Victoria's Secret model has been
raped
and they have wings not one
of the odds
maybe they were gonna be Victoria's
Secret model and then that's exactly it
and then the blue hair until someone
lightly brushed their arm at Walmart
yeah and they gained 300 pounds because
of it yep it's just I'm just it's always
it's always and it's always a rape
that's completely unverifiable right
yeah and it's always used for example to
justify cutting in a line right
I'm just saying if you're just playing
the odds game you would think that like
if again if rape is horrible but if I'm
a rapist and again I'm not a rapist I am
anti-rape but if you've crossed over
you've crossed that threshold you say
you know what I don't care I'm going to
be a felon I'm going to inflict violence
upon a woman I'm going to have sex with
a woman who doesn't want to have sex
with me back so now the barrier entry is
removed the woman doesn't want to have
sex with you back wouldn't you pick the
one you most want to have sex with
it stands to reason you'd think there'd
be like you know they'd like monitor
someone like a Kate Upton find out when
her laundry day is jump in the hamper
and instead apparently they're in the
express lane at Walmart looking for blue
haired or uh Weird Al look alike or Lena
Dunham yes that kind well that's also
regretful sex there's a difference
between rape different and regretful sex
like Lena Dunham said it regretted this
and there's a difference between rape
and sexual assault yeah or difference
between rape and sexual harassment yeah
there are grades of this and you know
what we've really just lumped it all in
and here we are now where a woman like
this feels comfortable saying I was
raped therefore I should have 19 Grace
items in the 12 item checkout lane
nope I've never you I've never heard
rape used as as like you said an excuse
for cutting in line it seems like he
kind of went a little farther maybe I
have I'm in a hurry or something like
that oh I've heard it it happened to me
no it happened yes it happened to me at
the Piggly Wiggly I was like hey you
have 19 items in the checkout line and
she said rape what are you gonna do I
was like well what are you gonna do
she gets a pass for all those trans fats
in her best rake victims do with
self-checkout
that's what this was this was
self-checkout and she cut it that
all right
it was self-checkout wasn't it
self-checkout what was she yelling at
she was yelling at the checkout machine
oh no she was yelling at the guy who's
mad that she couldn't lie my point is
this uh if I have to bet my bottom
dollar she probably wasn't no uh oh uh
sorry I'm getting in my earpiece um uh
before uh breaking news
thank you
uh in breaking news it appears Carrie
lake has just officially become governor
of Arizona
I'm gonna do everything I can to make
sure that Carrie lake is not elected
well congratulations on that endorsement
Kerry
[Music]
all but guarantee she'll win Cheney
think is she delusional does she think
the people are like well oh well I was
going to vote for clay Lake but Liz
Cheney said I shouldn't
I couldn't get over a hundred thousand
people to vote for you in my home state
it's like if you vote for Trump you're
bad and people like oh well that settles
it thanks for setting me straight why
does any does Liz Cheney actually
comment you know I would love to hear I
would love to hear from the Liz Cheney
fan
if you're watching
you know anyone she's planning a run
they say then the president yeah please
do
I want if okay so I don't necessarily
want Donald Trump to to run unless he's
you know all in but if he is there and
she is there oh that will be oh my word
just catnip she won't even get a word
and she's like Halliburton Halliburton
oh Halliburton where were you with
Halliburton
look she doesn't want to talk about
Halliburton frankly why don't you want
to talk about Halliburton Liz it would
just be epic
she's a man
I feel like even if he doesn't run every
year he should be in the primary just to
make sure the field is strong just put
him in the debate through him yes it's
like it's a culling he's he's the
weighted vest yeah I love it
yeah I was running against her that's
like using a corked bat for crying but I
can't think of anyone easier all right
so uh this is one thing I I don't know
if you've been watching The Alex Jones
trial
I didn't know that when we did the Ash
Wednesday last Wednesday that was the
start of the Connecticut Trail yeah full
disclosure we had to pre-tip dash
Wednesday the day before sometimes we
have to do that because the way we set
up the cameras and often if we want good
guests they can't come in live
so I've been following it and here's the
thing um
first off there is a railroading that's
taking place if you look at the
prosecuting attorneys they've been very
clear this is not about Alex Jones it's
about silencing anyone else who may have
opinions like Alex Jones or a platform
like Alex Jones and to be clear I don't
agree with Alex Jones on everything I
agree with it more now than I used to I
just didn't like it when people tucked
tail and abandoned him when he was
de-platformed so we had him on
immediately and I still feel that way uh
it's just a compulsion but if you have
not been watching the trial
I want to get to the clip of recap
here's the theme Alex Jones is exactly
what you would picture him to be yeah I
spent a good amount of time with him and
on the stand he just cannot help himself
it's very endearing
you put a Target on his back just like
you did every single parent and loved
one sitting here you know these are real
people
move on just like all the Iraqis but you
liberals kill and love
it's just you're unbelievable
you switch on emotions on and off when
you want it's just ambulance Jason is
this a struggle session are we in China
American Gun Owners you might be a
blamed for this as the left did so we
would watch the final clip where he's
finally trying to get him I legitimately
thought about him on stage and I stand
by that I don't apologize for it and
don't apologize Mr Jones please don't
apologize I've already apologized to the
parents over and over again
don't apologize to you because there's
going to be another
sorry
[Laughter]
judge goes oh I'm sorry are you
objecting to your clients the objection
is sustained he doesn't have to answer
it right I believe it was a real
shooting but he was a part of a
government
MK Ultra he could not stop it
rocks are gay it looks it's so Earnest
like a child of Judge like Alex sorry
and here's the thing with Alex Jones too
the most egregious attacks that they've
used is not that oh okay he's he's awful
he's extremist what they try and say is
he's not genuine right you've heard them
say well as defense attorney said that
none of it was real it was all an act no
no that's not true what they tried to
say was that things being taken out of
context on a show sometimes they are
performative right I will tell you this
okay Alex Jones is a flawed person Alex
Jones has made mistakes he talked about
that on the show Alex Jones has made
some wrong calls Alex Jones off air is
exactly what you would expect him to be
to the point that when he's here he's
exhausting we have to assign it in a
good way yes in a good way yeah well
look it's really true it's great what
you've done with the studio what's this
costume here is that you know if you
want to do a sketch I can come back and
do this anytime you want anytime you
want is that ball rug I love Street
Fighter too yeah oh yeah yeah I was a
Battleground guy but really it only has
punches though you wish you had some
kicks but uh yeah but if you use the
electricity it's just one of those
things once you find out how to do a low
kick Pizza sorry
exactly I have three minute voicemails
from Alex Jones
nothing but he sends voice memos yes so
he hopes they expire so no one can
retrieve them at Discovery he'll send
one I don't answer and then he'll send
one arguing with his previous one
they're like Hey Stephen I want you to
you know I hear you might be uh riding
through Austin here I don't know if
you're in shame of mind so I would like
you to come by the studio I don't
respond it's like but I mean like six
minutes I was like
hey it's here I just don't know why
you're not coming by the studio you know
I thought that we kind of agreed on this
so I'll defend him with I'll defend him
I can't defend him on every single issue
as though he's right nobody ever is but
the attacks that he's not a genuine
person that's what they always try and
do oh you don't really mean it
um oh you're you're projecting as
another attack that they use remember
the the child pornography they tried to
claim on the hard drive that was the FBI
yeah yeah it was the FBI was the FBI I
don't remember the exact story they were
the ones with the child and they sent it
from some kind of an Infowars address
Alex Jones never once downloaded child
pornography never distributed it that's
why he sued The Young Turks when they
made those claims and then he stopped
once they stopped making the claims
because he said that was accusing me
knowingly deliberately of a felony not
being wrong about thinking that
something is staged do we have to go
through this is this this is remedial
right you can say things and be wrong
and that's protected you can't
deliberately lie about somebody by name
to try and cause irreparable harm
especially accusing them of a felony one
is completely protected one falls under
libel or slander depending if it's
spoken or uttered or if it's written
it's very clear we have laws for this
yeah well they're trying to make an
example of him I mean they even said it
they don't want any more Alex Jones
types coming up I'm like well Define
that you don't want people to make
claims that turn out to be true later on
that we were like ah we didn't believe
it can you pause really quickly
apparently a Tim Burton Helena Bonham
Carter's character is on CNN dear Lord
what is this with CNN bringing it yeah
and men now get successful like in a
large number to all right that's Sweeney
Todd's assistant okay sorry
another I mean they're just they're
trying to bankrupt him and trying to
keep anybody else from trying to follow
in his footsteps at all right right no
matter what your I mean they can do the
same thing to you they can do the same
thing to anybody that they don't they
could how long have I demonetized me
doing that well no I mean that's so
that's step one right step two is
de-platforming and step three is saying
hey even though you're deep platform now
and you have your own thing set up we're
gonna sue you into Oblivion right now
you're gonna have to pay legal fees and
be tied up forever and also pay these
ridiculous job what was the Judgment
against him well yeah but it didn't
matter I mean I think the maximum uh
maximum penalty was like five minutes I
know but the five million but yeah but
sorry five minutes five yeah five
million what do you have five minutes
without I was just looking at the season
minutes on the brain all right
uh by the way this is a live show Monday
through Thursday 10 a.m Eastern while
we're talking about being demonetized
but we're talking about being throttled
in Shadow band on YouTube the best place
to go to mug Club lottery.com it's
what's kept us going for a thousand
episodes we do a full uh full uh double
the show every uh every day Monday
through Thursday otherwise you can watch
for free here on YouTube or of course
Rumble nothing would throw me more
greatly than for you all to give YouTube
to boot and go to rumble but I can't
force you to so I'll give you the choice
to you yeah Rumble went public last week
by the way did that yeah their stock
symbol is awesome rum
perfect let's see what they did there
yeah that's a great way to set up a
company a dad pun yeah well then they
had the pirate flag too so that was cool
for them rapists no not really
everyone was willing someone by the way
commented last week when we're talking
about Sea Beast and the black lady
pirates and I were saying that she
clearly wouldn't have been apart because
she would have been immediately raped
someone said like well actually you know
you got that wrong a good portion of uh
Pirates were black that wasn't the point
I was making I said it was a woman of
course I know Pirates are black I saw
Captain Phillips
that's why we have the Marines leather
next because we had to deal with Islamic
part like no my point wasn't the pirate
was black my point was that the pirate
had tits I'm [ __ ]
all right
speaking of [ __ ] the way people are
covering Italy have you been seeing this
the shrieking have you seen that
crawdaddy this morning on CNN ah far
right wing and I want to get I want to
get through the truth versus their
claims here okay because I think it's
important because look you don't want to
be caught flat-footed if you're
supporting someone who let's say is an
actual I don't know ethno nationalist
don't worry that's not what's happening
it's totally fine you can totally be
happy that Italy has decided to reject
uh globalist liberalism now
um and let me know if you've been
following this or if you're in Italy
right now and you know you're still
alive uh you can just comment below and
let us know what you've been
experiencing there so uh Georgia Maloney
uh and the the party is uh the brothers
of Italy party
and there's a right-wing Coalition uh
they won okay Sunday's Italian elections
just to be clear now of course you see
this right away from the media and uh
this is this is their playbook their
claim is right away this is a far right
fascist new government
baloney is Young
charismatic and
punches many of her fans can't get
enough of her straight talk it doesn't
seem to bother anyone here that many
people in Maloney's party are supporters
of former dictator Benito Mussolini or
that the flame on his tomb is her Party
symbol Georgia Maloney has gone from
little sister status among fellow
right-wing leaders to now owning them on
her way to becoming the first female
prime minister of Italy and the head of
the most right-wing government someone
give her haircut the Taco Bell gong
what's this Victory mean that this will
be the first time since the end of World
War II and the fall of fascism that
Italy has been led by such a far-right
leaning coalition government okay
what
did you hear the reporters say that some
of her supporters were actually
supporters of Mussolini yeah I don't
know how that works can people do math
in life Mussolini was dead I don't know
exactly what year by but at least 19.
there might be a couple of people of
course who are still around Mussolini
exactly I don't understand the
indoctrination starts young they're 79
now or something I have no idea that's
the most ridiculous there you have on
ventilators
yeah no covet took them out do you have
any idea how many toddler pole pot
enthusiasts there are I have no idea I
didn't know it was a thing Milton
Bradley now um the Atlantic put this uh
put this succinctly they said Maloney
would also represent continuity with
Italy's darkest episode The interwar
dictatorship of Benito Mussolini okay
brief history lesson the fascist party
was banned in Italy after World War II
okay uh and the party right now is very
very far removed from the Italian social
movement which is a by the way successor
to the fascist party now Maloney just to
be clear these are her own words I don't
know if we have a Clipper we have a
quote I think we have a quote here yeah
uh where she's rejected fascism and
she's already addressed this this is the
Playbook right they did it with Donald
Trump I haven't heard the reality check
guy on CNN talking about this and
relating it to Donald Trump and then
we're letting Putin to Donald Trump so
reality yeah
that's true that's a reality check what
it's gangster style so uh this is what
uh she said Maloney uh uh or sorry what
is this that says uh saying the Italian
right she was saying this about the
Italian right uh handed fascism over to
history for decades now and quote
unambiguously she condemns the
suppression of democracy and uh the igno
uh ignomanias anti-jewish laws
ignominious ignominious whatever
you're Canadian ish that's honestly I'm
not going to take that's a word that I
really haven't used very many times
so here's the thing uh first off
Mussolini was a socialist was a
socialist up until the day he died so
I'll get to that in a second but if this
party is synonymous with fascism right
they're trying to say because this was
the precursor to uh uh Mussolini yeah
um okay the last time since it was
outlawed a post-world War II right the
last time you would have had anyone who
has any roots in fascism or Mussolini
you'd be talking about I'm talking about
the 40s 50s right depending uh when
you're looking at people maybe there's
some remember it was an underground
fascist railroad but if this is the
party of fascism because you have to go
that far back right through the analysis
of History see and we made up for
amazing in other words uh then
by comparison the current Democratic
party is the party of slavery the party
of segregation the party of internment
camps
because they were still Pro those things
well fascism was outlawed in Italy yeah
in other words things changed now of
course the party swap as a myth we've
talked about that that's not really true
when people try and point to Strom
Thurmond they don't really understand
the historical context but my point is
this Democrats back then in that same
period of time were against integration
they still believe in segregated
drinking fountains segregated uh you're
talking about they oppose a Civil Rights
Act yeah so at what point do we say well
look I don't like Democrats today but
they aren't trying to you know Chase
black people down with German Shepherds
because they're trying to have a slice
of pie up at the counter yeah well and
so this is like you said just like
Donald Trump where he said there's very
fine people on both sides and right
before that said white nationalists are
condemned totally anybody in that she's
making the same kind of claim like hey
I'm not saying there's fine people on
both sides she's saying that I'm
condemning that that is something that
we've left in the past fascism is gone
right right I I believe in none of that
and what I do believe in is freedom
their term like they're changing Freedom
individual freedom and liberty into
fascism well and here's the thing the
only reason that fascism is seen is
right wing is because they try to change
the definition if you go on Google right
now it says is inherently right wing so
they try and so so therefore Hitler is
right wing Mussolini is right wing pull
pot is right wing Mao is basically right
wing the only way fast I don't
understand how people have gotten away
with this fascism can't function unless
the government is bigger and more
important than its people that requires
big government so certainly not as you
would relate it to the American right
wing now here's a fact for you do we
have a stinger for it or no yeah I don't
okay all right so there's a claim that
okay Mussolini was a fascist Mussolini
was right wing here's the truth that's
the claim hit the truth
it's a live show there you go yeah
so before forming the fascist party
Muslim was a devout socialist and by the
way he was still a socialist so this is
actually what he said after being a
fascist here's a quote everything in
this well let me read like Muslim
everything in the state nothing outside
of the state nothing against the state
it was like a Jewish Mussolini does that
sound like Donald Trump does that sound
like Ronald Reagan
clear talking about Americans as fascist
what they've tried to do in CNN and
Titan can you point me to one single
ever and this is genuine I'd like for
you to comment below one single fascist
government that supported more open Free
Speech as conservatives and Donald Trump
did and more people having access to
firearms name me one ever
it's not possible no okay she needs to
flip the narrative on them and we need
to do this fast like Trump did with fake
news yeah right it's got to be done
because it's really clear and easy to
prove yeah that's incredibly easy and by
the way this is also part of a big Trend
in Europe This is why they're afraid of
it right so right-wing leadership they
made huge gains we have we have what's
just happened in Italy yet what just
happened in in Sweden you have Spain you
have France you have Le Pen you have uh
Hungary so this is also what's
interesting is um you know Italy was one
of those countries we were watching in
case you don't remember early on in Coba
they have one of the oldest populations
in Europe if not number one their top
three I remember uh and so they had some
of the strictest lockdown measures
immediately in Italy yeah so they have a
very high death rate still Italy they'd
have overall if you're looking at deaths
per million and they had incredible
lockdown so it's very clear to the
Italian people hey all right we've had
to decide between freedom or uh you know
security they've lived through it we've
had incredible lockdowns and we've also
had a high death rate in other words if
they were to say well you know what we
should have done more because because
the death rate is too high you would see
very quickly right now an Embrace of
liberalism you would see an Embrace of
globalism you would see an Embrace of
authoritarian government of lockdowns
and instead everywhere it's been on the
ballot there has been a rejection of it
this is a rejection across Europe and
you're seeing it in the United States a
rejection of the pandemic measures that
were implemented and would have been far
more severe here if the Democratic party
had its way do not miss the macro
picture you are seeing this sweep across
Europe and in your own personal life I'm
sure that you know many many many many
many people who were pro-lockdown who
were Pro whatever it was mask mandate
vaccine all of it until they finally had
something affect them they said you know
what okay we went too far there's a
rejection of this this is an example of
that it is a rejection of what Italy did
during covid despite the fact they say
we have a high death rate we still think
we shouldn't have locked down that's
what this vote says yeah and people are
saying look freedom is worth it right
it's okay sometimes we're going to have
to face things that maybe can cause us
harm but freedom is worth it otherwise
you have the government Central planning
and the thing that led up to this and
you and I discussed this last week was
all of the uncontrolled immigration that
that they allowed in Italy was one of
the main focal points of all that from
North Africa people coming from North
Africa up through Italy and Italy was
being overrun they could not financially
handle it so they started sending people
up into the rest of Europe and that's
when the rest of Europe was like whoa
whoa wait a minute like our populations
they're not they're not coming here and
assimilating and learning the language
and trying to be a part of our community
they're coming here and living as their
own little community that hates our
country right that's what we can't allow
to have happen and that's what started
happening and Sweden started happening
Hungary UK right now they're talking
about it all the time France France and
then it didn't take much for them to
connect the dots and so the people who
want to change the fabric of our country
are also the people who know that they
can do it if they lock us down and
basically massimport migrants exactly so
and then covet hit and this was like the
last straw you're just seeing people go
no I'm sorry the government we are not
allowing the government to be in charge
of everything anymore well they give you
some contacts pre-pandemic Melones party
they only won four percent of the vote
this is back in 2018 I believe that's
not that long ago so think of that is a
huge shift who's a four percent
candidate right now listen it'd be like
if Liz chady won the president of being
generous
right whatever it's 2028 maybe that's
like Gary Johnson Gary Johnson yeah
there's at least four percent four
percent potheads no it's like hold on
better Kamala Harris that is though as
though Kamala Harris right the
presidency look familiar has got less
than four percent in the primaries so
actually I think you're being still far
too generous but the principle is the
same but you're going to see more of
this nationalism over there because they
are a people we're not we're an idea so
the Melting Pot works here we want that
we want people from everywhere from
every culture what's funny is they're
trying to have been diluted and they
hate that there have they've lost their
way in Sweden and in Italy and France
they're they're no longer eight people
well that's why it also makes them
nervous their nationalism because it's
tied more to a race as opposed to the
United States and nationalism is tied to
the ideas of the United States and I get
it they're going to say that most of
course people who settle this country
are going to talk about largely white
Western Europe I get it I get it I
understand it but my point is the
Italians do themselves as a people if
you don't believe it ask them about the
Moors they have a sore spot about that
the Greeks feed themselves as the people
the swedes be themselves as the people
uh the Germans view themselves as a
people in the United States we view
ourselves collectively as a people who
subscribe to these ideas as a nation now
they still shriek about nationalism in
the United States but in Europe they go
oh we've been here before because
nationalism let's be honest it's come
with some good and some bad historically
with Europe but it's not the same thing
as being proud of your country and not
wanting to be beholden to other
countries values that don't align with
yours we all were raised with this we
were kids we are the world right this
idea that the whole world we're all the
same no we're not we're not all the same
and you don't believe we're all the same
because there was the there were the
allies and there was the axis of Evil in
other words at some point we all draw a
line and say well you know what there's
a reason for borders the borders signify
us not having mutually aligned interests
or values and you're just seeing that
more clearly defined in Europe right now
especially with the EU and people
wanting to leave because they feel like
they're being held hostage and that's a
perfectly reasonable response for the
people of Italy so by the way Maloney's
entire platform you're going back to
2018 four percent of course covet is the
Catalyst for it but the whole platform
is not based around fascism it's not
based around racism it's based around
Freedom it's based around Faith and
family here listening for yourself
my
um
foreign
yes all those fascists who are
anti-eugenics and quote Chesterton
she stuck The Landing there didn't she
she did boy she nailed it she was
talking about not being made into a
number right she's like I'm not just a
consumer for speculators to make money
off of in these big corporations I am a
mom I'm a Christian I'm an Italian like
there are things that make me who I am
and you can't strip those things away in
her Chesterton quote I think we have an
overlay for that Chester it nailed it so
great Christian thinker obviously so
there's a lot of pastors right now that
are retweeting it's listening she said
fires will be kindled to testify that
two and two make four Swords will be
drawn to prove that leaves are green in
summer and he's talking about
flipping reality you'll have to fight
people
to show them that the leaves are green
and summer it's like an obvious thing is
true right what are we dealing with
right now in right American society and
in the world everything is because right
has become wrong like you said right
everything is flipped around and it's
like why would you ever have to fight
that he predicted that what's funny is
he meant it allegorically like you know
two and two equals four he didn't
actually think that we would be teaching
that two and two may not equal four
which is what we actually teach in
classrooms now tell us what you think it
could be 22. if you show the work right
everyone would say well Chesterton
that's a little bit extreme he's like
it's allegorical you silly [ __ ] yeah
but only now it's literal
Rashida Talib but she's easy on the eyes
right no you're right she's not a
terrorist and the accent come on no
I don't know better looking than the CNN
anchors I'll tell you that all of them I
don't know and I don't know when that uh
Italian genetics bomb drops because you
know it's like it seems It's almost like
you turn you're beautiful beautiful and
you turn into one of the clumps yeah
it's like either they are a beautiful
stunning woman or a house
it's like carbs ketchup how often how
often have you ever seen a in a a pretty
like 50 year old Asian like woman
you see they look as though they're 20
or 99 that's true it happens how old was
swalwell's spy
I don't think he asked which one
I assuming a squadron of Chinese spies
this guy by the way is still still
darkening the halls of our elected
representatives Eric swalwell was sexing
a Chinese spy yeah
I don't know how that's like not
subverting democracy all right so here's
my question to you as well notice while
they talk about fascism because fascism
of course if you go and watch the change
my minds and all the references are
available at clutter.com they always tie
it in with the patriarchy right because
patriarchists are fascists or fascists
are patriarchists uh you notice a huge
portion of them are women
the Maloney you have Le Pen people like
Carrie Lake you notice there's a
disproportional number of fascist women
out there apparently well representation
matters
oh and here well here's some in the
Atlantic tries to cut this off of the
past we were reading this this morning
uh it offers us it says Maloney is
comparable to Le Pen in other ways both
are examples of what political
scientists call gender washing when
female politicians adopt a
non-threatening image to blunt the force
of their extremism uh by being women
they don't adopt that they are that it's
science
by the way how is that not sexist adopt
a non-threatening image you've always
said that the idea of a demure
submissive woman right that's sexism
you're trying to say they're adopting I
didn't see anything there
non-threatening I didn't see anything
they're fascist I saw it incredibly
threatening which is why you have to
invent terms like gender washing
you completely pompous Pricks this is
where they are I was gender washing they
try and cut it off at the past it's
actually no hosting your opinion is
actual violence okay well I guess I just
won't say well actually no wait silence
is violence well I don't okay you know
what you're racist well you know what
actually I I I believe that all people
are created equal well that's just
colorblind that's another form of racism
hey you're you're part of the patriarchy
hold on a second this is a woman who
actually well no actually you're just
gender washing this is what they do they
cannot argue in the form of ideas so
they say right-wing extremist well
what's your right-wing extremism she
believes in the sanctity of life she
believes Freedom she believes that you
should be able to make your own choices
she's part of the patriarchy hold on a
second this is a strong woman who uh no
gender washing who's a stronger woman
let me ask you this Carrie Lake
but we're talking about the new the the
new uh I just Mark I can never get her
name right Maloney I was going to say
marioni which is a slightly racist on my
part
Maloney Carey lake or that girl who just
claimed she was raped at Walmart when a
guy lightly raised her forearm hair oh
yeah
strong independent woman who are the
weakest Among Us
it happens all the time
I've throughout my life been exclusively
attracted to strong women I don't know
that you can find a strong woman on the
left because they don't believe that
they have control of Their Own Destiny
and I won't get into predeterminism
versus you know occasionally all that
stuff but you understand what I'm saying
the idea of making your own choices and
being responsible for your own decisions
I see it exclusively I don't know how
you can be a strong woman man anything
on today's left I realize it's it's an
inherently weak position that's why you
also think of them as weak and wimpy
because
it is
what's the name of her party over there
what does it translate to the Fratelli
is it Brothers uh the brothers of I I
don't know so she's brother's right wing
she's blunting that male aggression
there in the with the name she'll be the
Z party yeah let me say it is it is the
I'll make sure I have this name right it
is the brothers of Italy party
Brothers of Italy and she and she heads
it up
okay
just to be clear but I think it's
interesting she's one of those
self-loathing yeah yeah representatives
of the brothers it's very interesting
when we went into the show today uh CNN
had a segment on about her right and
they'll obviously they'll go back to it
and they'll just keep going and it was I
think it said Ultra right wing
I like to you know prime minister right
so it's this Ultra right-wing thing
every single time somebody comes on and
says I believe in Freedom I believe that
it's fine to be a Christian it's fine to
be a believer it's fine to believe in
family because that's one of the things
she said right I'm a mother I have a
family it's fine to be an Italian right
and to say I want Italy I want Italians
to do well like they're saying that that
is ultra right-wing ideology yeah
wouldn't wouldn't no matter which party
you aligned with wouldn't you be fine
saying that shouldn't you be sure no and
this is the problem if you watch it
Nancy Pelosi was just a booed when she
was talking about you know a global
community and here's the thing when you
say I want Italians to do well
I will grant you this that means that
somewhere down the chain probably
someone else is not going to do as well
that's the nature of the world
if the United States is doing well if
you are doing if our citizens are being
taken care of that means there probably
isn't as much money left over for I
don't know NATO U.N I'm okay with it but
there's a difference between saying I
want to exploit others yeah you know for
personal gain personal gain at the
expense of others versus saying look we
need to prioritize our people we are a
nation this is not something this is
something too if you look at the history
books all of human history has been
incredibly you were at a point in
history right now that has never existed
ever people being mad at Russia because
of violence
that's that was the nature of the world
you wouldn't have seen people you think
Genghis Khan would have looked at
another Empire and said ah Matt I'm mad
at them because they're violent they
have no right to that lamb that's
imperialism no of course not you would
have the Ottomans the Turks the Romans
tribes right now in Africa violence has
been the law of the land forever and now
we exist in a time where that isn't the
case and people think that this has
always been the case and they want to
copy paste to you wait you want your
nation to do well there's that little
chip in their brain that thinks that
must be done at the expense of others
raping resources whatever it is ethno
environmentalism targets marginalized
Frontline communities whatever [ __ ]
term they want to make up that day oh it
just means that you want your people to
do well first anyone out there don't you
don't feel that way about your family
right when you say I want what's good
for my family are you talking about
abusing somebody else
no but there's an opportunity that must
be missed for someone else if let's say
you get a good job that means that
opportunity is no longer available for
someone else you compete for it why
because you want to feed your family
nations are the same and it's okay it's
a good thing maybe if we had clearer
borders maybe if they had clear borders
at that Walmart that little rubber that
little rubber baton that woman wouldn't
have accused that she was raped I don't
know and they need to do better too can
you think of an Italian contribution
recently no of course if you're going
back yeah sure about history but no and
they've been resting on their Laurels
that's right yeah the country of leisure
some people go there for the Vatican
yeah
um she wants to make them relevant right
what's wrong with that no that's a good
point hey by the way while we move on
here uh before we move on to the next
segment which is completely unrelated to
what I'm about to show you do you
remember the promises that you were all
made regarding the vaccines initially
and the efficacy rates
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
remember that that's a foreshadowing for
something that we'll play later
completely unrelated now completely
unrelated completely unrelated and my
question to you is have you been on this
segment have you been vaccinated
yourself and if you have or you haven't
have you gotten covet I have not been
vaccinated I've had the covet I've had
covet at least once and not been
vaccinated yep and I was fine I know
that's anecdotal but everyone in our
family at one point had it wasn't fun no
one's saying it's fun both things can be
true weren't necessarily weren't
vaccinated had coveted wasn't as bad as
a flu that I've had just anecdotally
okay just to be clear and I think that
you should be able to make the choice
for yourself like if you agree with that
that helps with the algorithm now
on a completely unrelated note as we
mentioned excess deaths in Europe
reached a plus 16 in July that means
they've gone up 16 when you're talking
about year over year uh June it went up
seven percent may it went up seven
percent and then this summer in the UK
alone they saw 21
475 excess deaths
now
we're going to get into the claims as to
why this is the case just to be clear
only 12 000 of those approximately
mentioned covet on the death certificate
so I think we need to get into what is
most likely to be the claims if you
haven't read about the story it should
be one of the biggest stories across the
world right now I mean for crying out
loud when people were dying of anything
for two years we were told that it was
covid there was a Ticker on CNN notice
there's no ticker anymore yeah so excess
deaths
what are the causes of it okay let me
first and then I'll let Gerald because I
know he wants to sink his teeth into
this here here's the claim that they
will initi the most lazy claim in its
most easily refutable is that most of
these excess deaths or all of these
excess deaths are somehow uh
attributable to covid or covid related
effects what's the truth Gerald the
truth is uh that it doesn't mean that
it's actually a death from covid right
so it could be a byproduct of something
that happens with covet like infection
like heart disease right so lockdown
related health conditions like poor
mental health who could have possibly
foreseen the people's mental health
would be impacted by being locked down
and not able to go out and interact with
you mean every single Doctor Who
expressed concern about it and then was
labeled to quack
are removed from YouTube right uh no but
they didn't have good opinions uh about
that bad diet lack of activity lack of
social uh kids games a lot of weight my
nephews gained like 10 pounds each wow
kids were already fat and then no they
lost it immediately right when the doors
opened again right but poor diet I'm
like oh you just you're just inside
white you don't have to change what you
eat you shouldn't hit your kid but you
can hit the food out of his palms yes
well and also so think about this so
many people that were sick like my dad
for example people that were sick that
needed medical attention that all of a
sudden became super afraid to go to the
doctor or go to the hospital because
they thought oh my gosh if I get out one
I'm getting out right I could possibly
get cover but two I'm going to a place
where people have covid right right so
they're very scared so they're not
getting the preventative treatment that
they need for stuff well that's exactly
the thing when you look at the list so
again the laziest people so watch your
YouTube pundits and people on CNN and
ABC NBC the laziest argument but these
are covet related but even the people
who are One Step up further down the
trail and say well okay maybe these
aren't necessarily code related but
they're related to these uh sort of
auxiliary effects from covet and I don't
necessarily even mean long-haul covered
but like you're saying lockdowns like
you're saying people weren't able to get
access to medical care because we were
overburdened which wasn't the case
basically hospitals weren't taking
patients because there was an incentive
to especially focus on covid related
care and they say this the left will say
these things without just like a Liz
Cheney there's such a lack of
self-awareness we're going yes
this entire time we were saying locking
people down indefinitely and decimating
the economy and yes people not being
able to get access to necessary medical
care because everything has to be
focused on covid right now despite many
hospitals at these varying points in
time being empty having capacity yes but
now they say see it was covered related
thank God we did all of these things
that led to these excess deaths yeah
absolutely and going back to Italy right
when they were doing the lockdowns do
you remember what the who said
lockdowns are not a great idea right
this was at the very beginning
for quoting the who I don't want to go
two for two on this I'm just saying
that's what they said right is that what
I said
here's the next claim that they'll make
because they if it doesn't work they're
covered related yeah this is one you're
actually seeing it's it's the fault of a
heat wave ah and we actually excuse me
we actually just got a clip um from the
who's Secretary General uh making the
claim about heat waves It Won't Get
Fooled Again real quick so far we have
broken all-time high in UK If you
haven't yet broken Secretary General
Europe in Sicily last summer we had the
48.8 degrees and so far we haven't been
exceeding that number yet so we expect
to see uh increased deaths among the old
and and always sick people okay so
here's what's key we gave them
Refrigeration didn't we also you have
air conditioning you can acknowledge me
that was the world media meteorologist
meteorological yes organization [ __ ]
so this is what's important because they
make a claim and this is the one this is
The Wonder of the left it must be so
nice just like I was raped she yells in
Walmart and I was like well hold on a
second that doesn't excuse your behavior
now rather say oh that's called the desk
he said well hold on a second now it's
not ah sorry did I say code but I meant
Heatwave
but that's not what you just said and
now you just said heat wave you just
heard him say so we expect to see excess
deaths in the elderly in the infirm
which is well that's going to bring us
to some other truths here that's not
what we're seeing with the excess death
so that's what he said but also
according to an article in the
conversation discussing the deaths in
England and Wales they said heat waves
are associated with increased deaths
especially in older and more vulnerable
people again older and more vulnerable
people the July heat wave in particular
was associated with a marked peak in
deaths both among people with kovid and
people without covet well then why
mention covet it's completely unrelated
it's like the heat wave was associated
with deaths in both men and women black
and white yellow no one knows are we
back to Johnny Mathis quotes just say
increased deaths
period you don't need to put covet in
but covet tests well right so here's the
truth
sure some old people can die from heat
yes absolutely that's true but more die
from cold
far more old people die from extreme
cold to be clear so the hottest day in
the UK in 2022 uh it was 104. 104
degrees jeez that is hot that's hot but
people aren't dying in record numbers if
they're in a house with air conditioning
or in a house with a window fan right
and certainly not young people we have
104 all the time in Texas and by the way
you just need to go back I don't know
three decades and most people here
didn't have air conditioning yeah
that's true and it's not old people that
we're talking about we're talking about
the excess deaths you have these numbers
I believe right here with you in the UK
younger groups have been showing the
excess mortality and by the way
attributed to non-coveted related causes
which wouldn't stand to reason if it's a
heat wave right if it's a heat wave
right we talked about people being older
and so we're going to focus on all the
groups below that weakening August 19th
in the 0 to 24 range it was up 17.4
excess deaths up 17.4 percent 0 to 24 25
to 49 up 9.8 percent 50 to 64 up
20.83 percent those are not people that
you would classify as the elderly that
are subject maybe 64 year old okay fine
whatever if you've made some really bad
Life Choices I get it that's gonna be a
hard thing or if you're informed but
we're talking about pretty healthy
groups that are seeing huge spikes on
the back of other spikes in June and
July already right so this is the
weakening in August they don't list Heat
Wave by the way is a reason for the desk
just so you know this is one of those
things what they want to do is when
there's objective there's objective
verifiable data notice they don't point
to the data they try and point to
science when it's convenient early on
with a vacciness of 99 I said one one
shot is 97 if you get two shots that's
99 something percent and all the
references are available sorry we said
that we met 50 we meant 82 then once it
got lower they said you know what uh the
vaccinator and the unvaccinated can just
you know what at this point just do what
you want and he said well hold on a
second why would you say that why would
you say that when you said it was 99
it's the same thing here you can see the
cause of death and I'm by the way I'm
also listing the causes of death where
of course we know they are over counting
covet does even when they're trying to
lie to you they can't the listed reasons
for the causes of death in young people
cerebrovascular disease heart failure
cancer respiratory disease heart disease
right these are the and by the way while
you're about to say heart disease when
they try and say that's covered related
just to be clear this is again you have
this in the journal of clinical medicine
this is published this is peer-reviewed
uh a 2020 study found that and they
looked at 200 000 patients and by the
way they found no increase in
myocarditis after Cova 19 infection
which of course is listed under heart
disease and a reason if you look at the
UK for the excess deaths none whatsoever
including acute covid and long-haul
covid so the idea that covet itself is
responsible for these heart
complications what happened to pointing
to the science to pointing to the data
we have it we didn't have it when you
were speculating we didn't have it when
it was not science it was still testing
a hypothesis in 2020. now that it's been
tested all of a sudden we don't have a
ticker all of a sudden no one wants to
talk about the numbers we have verified
the hypothesis now were we correct were
we not
no one's referencing the numbers which
we now have journal of clinical medicine
that's a far right-wing propaganda
Outlet right yes yeah yeah yeah so we
probably can and 200 000 people couldn't
possibly follow 200 000. it's operated
out of Jenny McCarthy's Den yeah by the
way when you have those polling numbers
that you see up there that's like 2 000
people okay that they've called to give
you those numbers to tell you who's
going to be your next leader necessarily
200 000 patients myocarditis that was a
big concern for a lot of people I'm not
saying there's any connection
with anything I'm just saying there was
a big concern before election was to the
vaccine not to cover the son of a [ __ ]
I was saying not saying something for a
reason sir no but people were worried
about the connection here we're not
saying they're swear to you Pops Crowder
if we get banned for that I'm taking it
out of your allowance
hypothesizing well okay we believe that
this could be our hypothesis this could
be related to the vaccine and yet other
people saying no no no no the increase
in myocarditis is it's actually because
of Spike protein from covid right right
so in other words there was no denying
no side denied you won't find anyone at
the highest levels of medicine denying
that there was an increase in
cardiovascular complications namely
myocarditis everyone acknowledged that
the only argument that was taking place
is well is that due to the organic
nature of the Spy protein and covet
itself or due to an acute for example uh
engineering of the spike protein with a
vaccine now I'm not giving you a
definitive answer I'm saying that was
the argument in the medical community we
don't have all the answers we do have
one answer yeah myocarditis the the
chances of of being a victim of
myocarditis do not increase at all
whatsoever due to covet in and of itself
200 000 patients monitor over acute
covet infection and long-haul covet
shows you that's it it's over it's done
now yeah and by the way when that was
brought up as a concern it wasn't like
hey that's a fair point let's look into
that and make sure it was you're a
science denier you're trying to get
people not to take a vaccine because of
this right so you're one of these
right-wing people that's exactly what
the response was and in the medical
community the response should be every
single time we need data right this is a
concern we need to make sure that we can
rule this out we have it now
we see it right now 200 000 patients
published well like you said that
where's the apology to our world it's a
test tube no it's like yes like every
major city that's run by democrats is a
test tube of their ideas well the world
is a test tube of coven now we've been
through it well you know and here's one
of the things I'm not going to say like
some people on the right say well
obviously lockdown's made it worse now
what I'm saying is the effects were
negligible for example when you look at
the United States and you look at the
top states of code sure you have
Mississippi at the top okay Florida is
somewhere I believe I'm going by Road 11
14 and right above it is New Jersey and
not too far below it is New York
honestly when this first happened you
can go back to the show I said if covet
is affecting the elderly oh my gosh it
is going to rip through some communities
in Florida I mean what do you think is
going to happen with all the all the
elderly wasps or well I guess I don't
know in Boynton Beach what it is right
now could be Cuban could be you my point
is they're old what do you think is
going to happen in the Boynton B at the
Boynton Beach shuffleboard Court I was
saying this is this is tailor-made to
take out Florida it's like God's waiting
room down there exactly do you think
those guys are going to stop having sex
with each other I'm surprised the entire
it's not gonna happen the entire State
isn't just covered in that butcher paper
that you have when you're sitting and
you know what the truth is well it
didn't do the best didn't do the worst
and neither did uh New Jersey New York
Michigan they're all within Striking
Distance of each other yeah so was it
worth it to completely destroy the
economies as you saw in places like New
York New York City as you saw in places
like Michigan was it worth it if you
look at economy for example when you
look at Italy again there are some
countries that have done better than
others and there are more variables that
go into it I know this is the I sound
like the person who the left claims to
be or I'm saying there are different
variables it is nuanced depending on the
population density it depends on the
demographic of the country but the point
is we can verifiably say that lockdowns
didn't help I'm not saying they hurt as
far as increase the spread but they did
hurt the economy that's verifiable
there's no doubt about that and they
certainly cannot be claimed to have
helped slow the spread
so we know that now so what could just
to be clear myocarditis Health
complications right these have
contributed to the excess deaths in the
UK and we know that those ex those would
not be complications from covet in
itself references available at lotto.com
so what could be the distal cause
the medical term
nice job sometimes I use this yeah
of these deaths well again you remember
the the music before so incompletely and
totally unrelated news here's young
healthy people falling down
foreign
[Music]
episodes like share helps with the
algorithm comment below I will be taking
some of your best comments here in the
next couple days on chat your favorite
moments memories or aspects of the show
because we are definitely looking at a
thousand more we're going to play
Photoshop or not YouTube
I mean I know
I know we were in some gray territory
here for you guys and by that I mean uh
medically verifiable data you're not
fans I understand it Different Strokes
so now you can piss off